i acted in a way
that made people feel uncomfortable
it was unintentional and i
truly and deeply apologized for it
i feel awful about it
and frankly i am embarrassed
by it new york governor andrew cuomo is
really sorry folks
not for his part in all the unnecessary
nursing home debts he's sorry for all
the mounting claims of sexual raps
being leveled against him but not enough
to resign
despite repeated calls from members of
his own party
here now fox news senior meteorologist
janice dean
she lost both of her in-laws thanks to
governor cuomo's incompetence
uh janice my friend i we continue to
pray for your family we know this is a
difficult time for you you have been
fighting him to the nail what is your
response to that press conference
pathetic but i i guess he is trying to
keep his emmy award
with his sad performance i'm so sorry
and you know two of his um accusers
basically said he lied and he shouldn't
have been saying all of that today
because it can be used against him in a
court of law
janice how deep is this because it seems
like
from what i hear from my sources and
i've interviewed many families
not only did he go after kim
and democrats officials but he went
after victim families
he tried to actively intimidate and
conceal
information
he did yes he tried to cover up
six or seven thousand deaths that
happened in the hospital like my
mother-in-law
and we only found out because his top
aide melissa de rosa said
in a closed-door meeting that was leaked
that they were afraid what was happening
with the justice department
yes he has lied he has never apologized
to the families by the way
he apologized today to his accusers
because he didn't know he did anything
wrong
it's just pathetic lawrence and you know
what we'll never see a resignation from
this guy
his ego is too big but i hope that his
words get him into trouble
i really do janice
you're not a politician you're not
someone that gets involved
you know we're your office is right down
from mine and i haven't seen you a
little bit
but you know the saying i always say if
anyone
upsets janice then you're a bad person
did you feel pushed to the edge
to get involved this is not something
that you do
i'm not a political person no one knows
who i voted for but this has
deeply affected my family and i'm
standing up for them
my husband's parents and the 15 000
families that want
answers and have not gotten them yet
i'll continue to do all i can to raise
awareness
because they deserve that
janice why did it take a sexual
harassment scandal
for him to finally apologize
is it more damaging embarrassed
i think it's easy for lawmakers to get
on that me too train
than to actually accuse him of the
criminal behavior
that i think he's guilty of yeah
janice we continue to pray for you thank
you so much for joining us my friend
thank you my friend